what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 6th of june the joint is
brought to you by liquid iv it's getting
hot out there [__] you better
stay hydrated one stick of liquid iv and
16 ounces of water hydrates you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone liquid iv comes in
tremendous flavors i've been telling you
guys i like the strawberry the concord
grape the acai unbelievable contains
five essential vitamins and vitamin c
it's non-gmo free from gluten dairy and
soy
liquid iv is on a mission to change the
world and has donated over 20 million
servings globally listen to me liquid iv
is tremendous i had covered and i've
been hooked on them since the cobra they
taste good
they're tremendous
they hydrate you and guess what else
they're quick and you got it right there
with you grab liquid iv in bulk at
nationwide at costco you get that costco
no big deal or i'm going to give you 25
off when you go to liquidity.com
and use promo code joey 25 off and i'm
also going to give you 25 off anything
you order when you use promo code joey
at liquid iv experience better hydration
today listen they had hydration they got
the one with the vitamins in it oh my
god liquid iv
is the best grab liquid iv right now 25
off go to liquidity.com and use promo
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by draftkings do you know what's
going on this week
it's ufc 275 and it's [__] stacked
you got glover you got joanna versus
chung way you got valentina you got like
10 [__] tremendous fights it's time
to get paid laid and parvated at [__]
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc you
got basketball playoffs too new
customers you bet 5 hours on any ufc 275
fight and get 150 and free bets
instantly no questions asked knockout
submission judge's decision and i poke
no matter who wins or how the fight ends
you're getting [__] paid now if
you're looking for a bigger payday oh
check out draftking's newest feature
same game paulie's you combine multiple
bets for your shot at a bigger payout
play same game parlay for saturday's
fight the more
legs you add the more money you win and
if it hits you'll double your [__]
earnings who's better than you but the
party starts at draftkings so do me a
favor download the draftkings to
sportsbook app today use promo code joey
you put five dollars on ufc 275 and you
get 150 and free bets instantly that's
code joey this week on draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the ufc plus you got nba
playoffs the prop bets on draftkings are
[__] tremendous how many points will
[__] what stephen curry have you want
to bet five three pointers draftkings
right now download the draftking sports
book app download the draftkings fantasy
app whatever the [__] floats your boat
use code joey and let's get paid
saturday night let's get this [__]
party started
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint it's monday june
the [__] sixth
holy [__] uh
i want to thank everybody who came out
to the shows in atlantic city this
weekend and i saw you [__]
walking around and whatnot
i gotta be honest i've been doing comedy
for uh you know a long [__] time and
this was just insane
it was insane it really was the amount
of people
the amount of love you know
people were really happy
you know thank god there was no
incidents or anything like that i mean
you know
across the [__] way they shot six
people in philly last night or something
i mean you know the [__] don't stop but
anyway we're not here to [__] talk
about that
you know i have not been around more
than 2 000 people since the pandemic i
went to
the sopranos premiere at the beacon
which was 2200 people something like
that
you know that's the most i've been
involved with
that place supposedly sat five thousand
forty eight hundred i gotta be honest
with you guys it felt like [__]
20 000 people i mean
there were people everywhere
i was gonna go down thursday night and
do a warm-up at the tropicana because my
friend eleanor was there kerrigan she'd
been on the podcast and whatnot she told
me to go down there for a workout but
the [__] skies were turning black on
thursday so i ended up going to uncle
vinnie's and just doing a little [__]
uh 15-minute spot a little warm-up there
was maybe 20 people in the room but it
was [__] superb
sometimes when you want to work out
a little crowd like that's why eleanor
was making me go down to [__] uh ac
because she goes
these are just people who come in you
know they don't wanna they don't even
know the comics they're probably waiting
for the bus back up north they probably
lost all their money you know because
when you you could take a bus from
anywhere to atlantic city they have
packages for you i don't know what it is
out of philly in north jersey it used to
be
when i was a kid it was 15 bucks
but when you got to atlantic city they
gave you 10 quarters
and they gave you coupons for
restaurants cigarettes you know all that
[__] and they give you a coupon for a
comedy club
so when you lose all your money because
when you go to atlantic city they want
you there for a while
i don't know vegas will take you but
when you're broke they're like get the
[__] out atlantic city they'll have you
hang out for a few hours just to see if
you can think of a cousin or something
you could borrow the last 200 from our
western union
i swear to god about 20 years ago i went
to atlantic city with my dear friend
jimmy berkel
we i used to meet him on tuesdays and
come to point pleasant it had to be i
don't even [__] know
i was doing comedy and i i went to
atlantic city with him to eat he told me
there was a place that all you could eat
crab legs and that they were really good
that he wouldn't [__] blood so i said
let's go down there
we went down there and while i was
sitting there somebody said to me joy do
you want to do a set now at this time
the guy came up to me goes aren't you a
comic and i go yeah you know i was like
a feature act i go yeah
and he goes uh at the comedy store right
and i go yeah yeah he goes i saw you one
night do you have 20 minutes i go yeah
he goes can you come over to the
tropicana
and do a
15-minute set we'll show it on comics i
said yeah when i walked in there that's
when i remembered that
these people i'm performing for like no
i'm lying to you people when i got on
stage and i started bombing
with material that you know i had been
on the road at that time i was on the
road every [__] day you know so this
material i was killing it was 20 good
minutes from the store i brought it in
front of these people doug
it was like doing comedy in front of
deaf people
they were just [__] depressed looking
at the floor i saw a lot of people
looking at their cards and [__] and i'm
like ah
remember that coupon that they gave the
people away for the bus
these are those people because what
happens is
they give you
let's say you take the nine o'clock am
bus
to atlantic city
they're not bringing you back until
seven they don't care what you say you
could be dying of a heart attack they
ain't bringing you back
you [__] came at nine you agreed to
seven and that's it you can't get on
earlier bust back so every hour that you
came like at nine o'clock people have to
live at a certain time 10 o'clock people
have to leave at a certain time
12 you know it just goes on and on and
it goes later so these people got to sit
around for that [__] but how long
does it take you to lose money listen it
takes me
eight seconds to lose 20 bucks in a
[__] uh a one-arm machine how do i
know because i just lost it saturday
morning i went for a walk in the casino
and i threw a 20 and it takes me eight
seconds to lose i'm exaggerating it
takes me eight minutes
to lose 20 you know you win a couple
[__] ding ding dings you know you get
the two [__] cousins or whatever you
win a little bit but then at the end you
just you get bored and you just go i
either hit me with a jackpot or take my
[__] money that's what they do it's
like back and forth i'm up 100 credits
i'm down 60 credits i'm back up to 200
credits and finally you just go [__]
this [__] i'm just gonna lose i lose you
know you just that's what you're there
for you know they got to pay me to
perform i might as well throw a 20 or 40
or lose i'm not going to [__] if
there's a sports betting and i could
spend the night i wouldn't [__] mind
but i wasn't going to spend the night so
i said [__] and i got draftkings why
would i [__] use them they're writing
my [__] phone so
that's what atlantic city was about
that's the last time i went to atlantic
city and then before that
i had been thrown by god a couple times
i did the ball god on my own a couple
times but again when you sign into the
bulgaria they tell you don't leave the
[__] building so it's not like you're
sight seeing all over atlantic city you
know what i'm saying saturday morning
when i woke up i had a window that was
facing the boardwalk in the ocean
i'm like this is [__] beautiful
my wife was i called my wife when i woke
up before i eat breakfast she's like
it's [__] hot out like i'm going out
there
i went for a walk bro and
it just wasn't right
like the sand felt kind of cheap
like everything
yeah it was like a storm [__] it just
didn't feel right the ocean smelled
great
i didn't really walk all the way out the
beach because uh a lot of people are
saying hello and [__] i mean everybody
was walking around it seemed like
everybody was walking around
was going to that show all shapes and
colors all sizes you know it was just
crazy you know there was some chinese
people waving at me like we're going to
the show and i'm like holy [__] you know
but they were really like asian you know
when you see like eight white guys and
an asian guy
but when you see eight [__] asians
they're like ah i was like holy [__]
every restaurant we went into there were
you know people that were going to the
show that said hello
the two guys from [__] philly showed
up my brothers we could not connect
that's why i went down to walk around
that's why i played slot machines i was
trying to meet those two [__] savages
i don't know where anything is
so they said meet by the front desk this
22 [__] front desk so i went down
there i walked around
i sat on the slot machine i [__]
played a couple one arms and then i just
said what am i gonna do i went up to i
couldn't [__] sleep
friday night
so i stayed up till like five just
listening to music with the earbuds i
was tremendous
no high no nothing i had to drink a
[__] shot of nyquil to finally
[__] fall asleep and then uh
friday night show guys
you ever walk into something you're not
sure
you ever walk into like a a new job and
you're really not sure and deep down
inside you're lost
but you're trying really hard to keep it
together that was me friday from the
minute i got in the car and i drove down
there
you know i had a bunch of people say can
i come down with you listen i want to
drive by myself just to clear my head it
was an hour and a half drive i wanted to
think of jokes you know i was one
listener [__] great music was on you
know when you go for a nice car ride
that's all i pray for i don't get a flat
and then i got great music on the
[__] ride i had my vapor pen i got
nice and [__] lit you know
but the whole weekend like as soon as i
walked in there friday
i brought a bag of edibles for the guys
from philly i brought bags of edibles to
give away i think i gave away
20 edibles
you know a couple of the show you know
what i'm saying just a couple
i gave away a ton of laughing gas down
there so if people can look at one of
those little uh we gave away i say guys
and they all say you know sample one
gram whatever but we gave away tons of
white truffle tons of rainbow ruts
tons of of sashimi
they gave away
my hat listen my hat's off to the
laughing gas people this week
they really it was just a great week for
[__] laughing gas and
you know i'm trying to really har i'm
trying really hard to get laughing gas
in new jersey at all these [__]
dispensaries
the sweetest [__] great guys and i'm
really proud of what they did with it
and
it gets you [__] stoned you know two
three bong hits you're rocking and
rolling and and then it's like a sleeper
weed sometimes sometimes you do it you
don't really like the other night when i
told you guys i smoked with tommy i
rolled a tremendous joint of rainbow
rutz and me and tommy smoked i got to be
honest i got in the comment i'm like
nothing happened and also i got to the
restaurant i'm like whoa
something did happen i told that way to
bring that bring that lobster biss
double quick jack seriously my god
cotton mouth and [__] so it's one of
those weeds
it creeps up on you you know i gave
something to my boy john rallo from uh
submit i forget the name of his gym down
in baltimore
and he hit me back the next day and he
goes man i smoke two joints i'm [__]
gone like he goes i smoked a joint
before breakfast and then me and my
brother smoked the number he goes but i
really like it i like how it tastes
guys i don't know much about reef or
what goes in it i can lie to you
terpenes i got the i don't know anything
these guys are geniuses my man scott my
man joe peps they're [__] geniuses
and uh
my hearts and my hats go off to them for
coming down i mean we were there was a
metal detector
and we were right by the metal detector
just giving out gram samples
and that when i woke up i went down with
maybe 10 gram samples i came out
right at the thing and then one of the
hotel guys came up to me goes man
i would love to smoke that but you can't
give it to me on camera but if you threw
it in the garbage
i said done
i go go over by the other security guard
i'll walk over that throw in the garbage
you come get it after i go upstairs when
the camera ain't on you know more boom
and that's exactly what i did we gave a
lot away man
and uh
i'm really proud of these guys i'm proud
to be a part with them we've gotten uh
everything worked out
and now we're going straight [__]
ahead so uh that was great that was
great but i didn't do any edibles i
wanted to feel it i wanted to see first
of all i'm not gonna lie that i was
scared of anxiety
it had been my first big big shout out
and i i thought i was gonna crumble but
guys i walked in there i kept it
together
uh
we went into the green room my heart
started beating a little bit the first
night i'm not gonna lie to you but then
i remembered that
if you don't
if you're not scared then don't don't be
there because you don't want to be there
you should be a little bit you know a
little bit of fear
when they called my name and i walked up
to the stage the first night guys
i had to control my ass so i took i was
going to blow a fart and diarrhea was
going to come out that's but i just
faked the funk
i walked up there i tried to keep it
controlled as i could some of the jokes
i said didn't work you know
i couldn't hear it it was such a big
[__] room you don't really know
what's going on
and i felt okay listen if you knew where
i was at i felt okay
just because i drove down there and made
it
just because of that i tapped myself on
the back
because friday morning i was looking for
an excuse i was praying that my daughter
would gave me that cover chair last week
i'm like let me get a test you're sure i
don't feel nothing i'm like joey what
the [__] is wrong with you
but that's what happens to all my trips
before i even before the pandemic when i
was on the road every week as soon as
that [__] uber came i'm fine as soon
as i get in the uber and i slam the door
and i check my wallet and i got my
[__] weed and everything i'm going
that's it i'm going to do a job
i'll see you [__] sunday
but leading up to that i get nerves so
what i did friday when i woke up guys i
was a mess
and i was going to leave earlier and i
go uh-uh i'm going to go to jiu-jitsu i
went to [__] jiu-jitsu
and i have the whoop watch and usually
when i press jiu-jitsu it's your heart
comes up and it tells you what the beats
are you know
i don't know what i was beating usually
on a regular basis but i know when i
tapped into [__] jiu jitsu friday
that thing was like a hundred and
something [__] beats a minute i'm
like i'm gonna have a heart attack i
started running i did some laps and
that's like the third lap
i i'm like oh this is not gonna work i
can't even catch my breath and i just
stuck to it i didn't give up i just
stuck to it by the time we got to the
squats and the [__] mountain climbers
and everything i got up i was hot i was
all discombobulated then we started
doing some drills and [__] also i'm like
my anxiety went away i forgot all my
anxiety for 25 [__] minutes gone i
was breathing normal i came home i
washed my [__] i had a [__]
cheeseburger mama made i pointed that
car south i put that [__] wave on
that's the name of the app waves
whatever the [__] and i shot down and i
said an hour and a half on the dot i
beat it by [__] three minutes it was
tremendous i like listen even the drive
didn't bother me like the one i didn't i
didn't get caught sick till last night
on the way [__] home
just
20 minutes before i got on the 18 i
think i had eight miles left to go and i
started feeling a little weird
i had to open up all the [__] windows
in the goddamn car and the air was
blasting i'm in there [__] dizzy
thank god i had a little water
i came home [__] saturday night i
walked in my daughter was up my wife
were up we watched uh
something that was on that me and my
daughter watched the honeymooners and
that was my [__] weekend guys
and last night i slept [__] fantastic
or saturday night i slept fantastic but
friday
i went back to my room
after it was all said and done and you
know i do my little [__] uh
stretching i jump in the shower
i get that cigarette smoke and that
malukia and covered air off your neck
and i
realized i couldn't fall asleep it was
because
my mind was racing a million miles a
minute from what i just saw you know
what i had just been a part of
i realized you know the last two years
guys i don't know where my head was at i
realized that i was part of something
you know i realized that
no matter how bad i want to pull out of
it
i'll always be a part of something
when i went to the philly game last
monday i was [__] around with people
and talking to the guys and my daughter
and jimmy
and the guy came over to me with his son
and uh
this was weird i didn't want to say this
but the son took a picture that
someone's a really nice guy
and his father came over he goes i
appreciate you taking a picture of my
son he goes i got two sons
he goes i got him and another [__]
clown he goes
this guy's okay my other guy is a bit
moody he goes except when you're on
he goes except when you're up
so he goes i just want to tell you i owe
you a dinner or whatever you want
because
you bring a lot of happiness to my one
kid this guy's all right but my other
one he's a little [__] slow you know
that's how philly people talk to you not
autistic not [__] you know he's got
levels no he's a little slow
when people tell you that about that kid
you're like this guy's all right you
know what i'm saying but that
it just all clicked for me at that time
he goes you know my son is down you make
him happy you know
and i was like really i don't know what
the [__] i do to make anybody i can't
even make myself [__] happy so
you know what man
i don't want to take it to where i was
but i really
i gotta get out of this house guys so
i'm gonna i'm definitely taking the
[__] uh
developmental show at the sony theater
in manhattan starting in september i'm
definitely gonna take that deal
it's just one saturday a month uh
you know and
i'm excited about the birth tour you
know this week i'm gonna go out with
rich voss a couple times
i'm gonna go out with jimmy i need to
get out two nights a week that's it i
just need to get out two nights a week
not [__] thursday friday saturday
sunday i'm busy here
but i had to find the happy medium and
i'm sure that we all go through that in
our lives where look at two years to
find the happy medium
two years so don't you know if you think
you're looking for a happy to figure out
how to juggle three things at once
your career your family you know listen
i don't have that career no more i don't
want that i don't i don't even have a
theatrical agent if one of my friends
wants to put me in a tv show
or in a movie so [__] be it
but if [__] uh
liquid iv [__] up is tremendous i
needed i took one yesterday morning
was i talking about i'm sorry
when i splashed my nose with the liquid
i drew now i got concord grape in my
nose i love it
but people always trying to figure out
how to juggle things
some people more intelligent some are
[__] [__] like me and it took me
two years to realize that
it's not whether or not i want to do
comedy it's that i need something in my
life and there's nothing else in my life
i've already done coke
i've already mugged people i've already
done time i've listened to all these
[__] albums 55 000 times which i
enjoy i wish i could find somebody to
pay me to listen to [__] music and
but i couldn't criticize music so why
listen you know i listen to music for
myself
but i think that was the best part
of the whole weekend you know
i realized a lot of things this last
week i realized that
my wife and i have to get out more
at night one night a week i realized
that uh
i have to get out more it's just
healthier for you i'm not a tv guy guys
i'm a movie guy
i love watching a movie on tv on the
television whatever but i'm not a guy
that
you know i followed the sopranos i was
home on sundays to watch it but i'm not
one of those guys
a lot of the shows that you got it's the
20th anniversary of the [__] wire
though today and today it had on hbo
uh what was it yeah
june 2nd was with the [__] 20 year
wow
so it was 20 years for the sopranos two
years ago and then
right during the wire they wow
that's how much into comedy i was guys i
didn't know what was going on in 2001
and 2002 i was just [__] you know it
was just a process a part of it
but even my wife this week we made a
decision she's going to get a job
uh
and she was like you know what i don't
want to go back to accounting
and she goes i want something light i go
then get a [__] job in massage
therapy you know massage envy you know
answering phones and she's like then she
went to a couple places and this is
where it gets tricky guys you sit
you drive everywhere you go to stores
how many [__] help wanted signs do
you see
they're everywhere
i think there's two shores that can't
open in jersey because they got no
lifeguards
they got no [__] lifeguards because
wildwood crest pays 20 an hour and the
other ones pay 13 so [__] that you
know it's it's arithmetic but that's not
the point the point is my wife went
to like four places last week one a day
just that she just saw there was a place
by target
she went to cold something like that you
know what everybody told check back with
us after july
check back with us here
check back with us there
you know if you're this [__] busy
i can't get hot you know i used to go to
jobs in the [__] 90s or when can you
start uh right [__] now
let's do this why [__] around what i'm
gonna go home and think about and then
not show up let's do it you know can you
start tonight can you start tomorrow can
you come up for training in two days she
went to like four places and they're
like ah we're gonna check back with us
in july she don't want to wait she don't
want to do another [__] she wants some a
mindless job she goes if i could [__]
pump gas i would do it without getting
mugged or something
so she decided a [__] great idea
she's going to go with a at a
where they don't kill cats
murder free shelter like one of those no
no kill yeah no kill shelters or
something like that
i think it's a [__] great idea i got
a friend from high school i don't know
her husband's rich every wednesday she
[__] volunteers she walks the dogs
she pets them and [__] i got to be
honest here i think i got to do
something volunteer too for four hours
like ants i can't listen they got one of
my friends is an emt and he always asks
me he goes if you ever want to
drive
how's your driver's license [__]
great you want to drive yeah i'll do
something
to help some people out you know i love
to do like meals on wheels or something
like that you know something they're
just medical transport you take people
from their house to the doctor's office
that's fun too get them high give them
an edible take up the [__]
chick-fil-a get them a chicken a non-gay
chicken sandwich and [__] chick-fil-a's
in the news again i don't know for what
but [__] you [__] all right
leave chick-fil-a alone they just they
even close on sundays which tells you
these [__] got class leave
chicken filet alone what's the matter
with you everybody else is bothering you
on sunday they come in get a deal
chick-fil-a don't say dick they're at
home count in [__] twenties so
whatever they're so what they i don't
even know what they did now i don't even
know what they did every [__] day boy
those chicken sandwiches don't bother
nobody and they're quick you go to
[__] costco
there's a [__] chick-fil-a by costco
that place is [__] mobbed constantly
but if you go there you're in another in
two [__] minutes i don't know how the
[__] they do it
they don't pay for women's uh
the medicine for
for birth control that's what it was
it's birth control and they don't cover
abortions under insurance
because they're catholic
yeah i'm catholic too but
but that's true too if i didn't [__] you
why am i paying you what i'm saying
if i didn't [__] you why am i paying
so
i don't know with all this abortion this
whole abortion [__]
i don't pay attention to it
i don't know
why people decide on what a woman's
[__] menstrual cycle or when she's
gonna have a baby or at one point i
don't i'm so disgusted by the whole guys
you've never heard me do an abortion
joke you've never had me break it down
i don't know if it's the catholic of me
or the [__] i don't know
i just never clicked on with that [__] i
don't like periods
listen there's only one thing about
[__] i like eating [__] all the other
uh matters of the [__] i have no idea
about i'm not a blood man i don't have
red wings for you nasty [__]
that eat period [__] with red wings i
got none of that [__]
you know i don't have any of that stuff
i i i must hate a period [__] once by
mistake but we're not even going to
discuss it because i might [__] faint
on location here but
i don't you know they every you know
road versus wade i just avoid the whole
[__] thing somebody got into a
conversation with me that is illegal to
keep them for that 20 weeks listen i
don't know it's got nothing to do with
me
move the [__] on all i know is it's
[__] monday [__]
it's june the [__] six
i got something interesting to tell you
maybe i don't know 1981
i went to see nazareth on june 6th
and they built it as a 666 but there was
like 2 6 but no
there was no [__] third six
because it wasn't 1986 it was 81. so i
couldn't figure out but that night
it was the [__] palladium i don't
know i don't know if you guys like
nazareth a lot i'm not a big fan of
nazareth i like uh don't even talk to me
about love hurts i don't want to hear
love hurts or every rose has his thorn i
don't want to hear those two [__]
songs but
what are we talking about
no the nasty concert was the palladium i
wanted to do louis castellito
and we went to this [__] show
and like i said i'm not a big fan of
nazareth i just loved going to see live
music back then they had that song the
album hair the dog and another one you
know
and we went there and hair the dog was
great but i'm going to tell you what
song till this day
i can't believe that they blew out of
the [__] water
cocaine
till this day it was the best version
i've ever heard of cocaine and it was
like it was one of those uh combination
acoustic like they all got off their
instruments it was like the first
unplugged
and they did like two songs but the
first one was cocaine
and it was [__] sensational
[__] sensational
things cover it in their
stuff
well listen there's two ways to cover a
song
there's the way to cover it the way they
did it
okay and i respect that you respect the
or
your interpretation of that song
what's really funny last night i was
driving home and i heard sympathy for
the devil live
and i'm thinking to myself
this doesn't sound anything
like the studio song
it's very all over the place i mean the
the uh the mechanics of it they're in
there you know
you know all that [__] the guitar solo
is really good but it was a different
like there were bongos involved and he
slowed it up a little bit and believe it
or not when i was younger i didn't like
seeing that but think about it guys it's
like a good joke
it's not gonna if you want that joke to
evolve you're gonna add all those layers
to it i've i'd love
i would love to write a 45 minute bit
on one topic just run with that one
topic you know
because think about it if you wrote
i don't know
a whole lot of love in 1969
and you're the
songwriter you arranged it you played
the instruments whatever
what do you want a whole lot of love to
sound like in 1990 if you wrote it in
1969.
so
when i'm used when you go see a live
band like one of these older cats these
older bands like i'm still looking for
somebody who's gonna do that
a lot of people don't have the courage
to do that because people paid money and
they some people might like i went to
see eric clapton
i don't know 92
people were born
because he did a blues he did it was a
blues tour but people wanted to hear
layla you follow me but back to
interpretation
think about it how if i had a whole lot
of love what have you heard prince do a
whole lot of love
there's a video on youtube right now i
wish you could put it up and we could
put it right here we don't have that
capability no more we have to need to
get that sign me up on that
[__] there's a thing about prince
prince has a video on youtube whole lot
of love
fresh from vegas
it's live from las vegas
that's what a whole lot of love you
wanted to sound like he
and that's what prince did
princeton interpretations when prince
did those
uh
shows in vegas where you would throw up
the idea you would tell them what you
want to hear
it was phenomenal but he did his
interpretation i heard he played i think
josh wolfe went to see him
josh wolf said somebody told him to play
nobody's fault for meryl smith one of my
favorite [__] aerosmith songs on
rocks
he said it was [__] fantastic and
then when i saw a whole lot of love i
stay i was on that video for a year
i would put it on every day he's
tripping the solos
oh my god it's a funky whole lot of love
that's what it is
it's a very funky whole i love this
inter his
interpretation guys i'm gonna tell you
something if there wasn't a thing called
joke stealing
it would be very interesting
to see what
other comics could do
with other comics
key jokes that would be something i
would [__] want to explore
how would
you know mike who's a nice guy doesn't
curse much how would mike do
with a richard pryor bit do you know
what i'm saying like somebody
against the corps that would be
interesting because i want to see what
you would do with that joke
so what somebody clean would do with a
dirty joke
and with somebody dirty do it a clean
joke
i've always thought about that
i've always thought about that because
listen like when there was one joke
thief that said that he didn't steal
people's jokes he just made him better
and by what he's saying is you got a
15-year comic 20-year comic that's a
veteran you got an open mica that's been
doing comedy for three years he doesn't
even know what to do with that joke
he really doesn't i mean he's but he's a
brilliant kid for coming up with it but
there's scumbag comics that would steal
those jokes
from those open micros and build them
into themselves
what is
a [__] kid in
missouri gonna tell you know i don't
know i'm just using a name here i don't
want to throw a name because then you'll
say i'm accused of a joke stealing joe
schmoe what if joe schmoe the biggest
comic in the world went to [__] in
montana
he worked for the weekend with some
young comic that was [__] tremendous
you know you could tell when somebody's
gonna be good they just don't have all
the tools but he had two or three jokes
that were right [__] there you like
those jokes are [__] pretty good
those are the jokes
professional comics would steal from
those young guys
and then take it
and
interpret it in their own way
you know a 20-year comic that's been
writing jokes is going to do way better
than a comic that's been doing jokes for
three years
and they do it it's very sad to a guy
like me i wouldn't do that to a young
comic was that that deflates everything
a comic has early on it's good that he
experiences it you know what i'm saying
it's pretty good that you experience it
so you know it's out there so you trust
no one
but it's kind of shitty to do and a lot
bro i i it happened to a lot of comics
years ago a lot of comics were
complaining that these big time comments
would come to their town maine you know
pittsburgh nobody's seen these guys
nobody knows who they are you could
steal their joke take it to l.a develop
it and one day you you're sitting with
your friends going let's go watch uncle
joey we i worked on him with helium he
was great and all of a sudden you're
seeing your [__] jokes on this
special you're like
that kills comics i saw comics that they
couldn't recover from that they just it
took a while to recover from that but
i'll tell you the biggest interpretation
i i
they're one of my favorite bands they're
in the top three favorite bands
i've always known about this you know
you try to avoid it you try not to think
about it because you love them so much
you know it's like somebody telling you
your favorite movie star did something
you're like i don't even believe it
because he would never do that you know
[__] like that
led zeppelin i love led zeppelin
i don't want to call him a thief
i don't want to call him a thief i will
call him
music
interpreters
you know
a couple years ago they had that case in
los angeles and led zeppelin won
i love led zeppelin but they lost that
case
if you listen to what those people did
and you listen to it jimmy and i love
led zeppelin i gotta be honest with
myself i'm a big fan of this dave
delingus sends me 20 books by them i got
20 books by them i've read 50 books by
them you know it hurts my feelings when
i look to [__] uh explain
music to people or stand up with a joke
i like led zeppelin that's why i'm a
[__] savage they're in my psyche i
love everything about them but the truth
of the matter is
they lost that [__] case
dog you guys know i love all law and
order even without the [__] degree i
could be a judge and i'd be partial and
favorite i'm always fair with people i'm
fair with my own [__] things i'd be a
great judge whoever judged that
and listen if i was the judge the only
reason i would favor led zeppelin is one
reason this is what i thought of not
even guys i don't even know if you guys
want to hear this or not i think it's
interesting the only reason why i favor
led zeppelin is this because if i gave
the [__]
money to the people who actually wrote
this song
if [__] these people would have
showed up a year after the album when it
came out we could have worked some out
here
but you showed up
50 [__] years after the album came
out guys
i don't know if that's exact i'll look
it up tonight i'm just tossing off the
top of my head here you showed up 50
years after the fact and listen when you
listen to the [__] people who wrote
it you listen to jimmy page's version
don't look me in the eye and tell me
that that's not the same the problem is
let me tell you why led zeppelin won
because how many people would have to
unbury and bury from the [__] grave
how many every time i hear zeppelin in
the [__] car i think of four people
my mother
anthony balzano dominic speciale and
this girl why because they played that
song at their [__] funerals okay that
song in the 70s if your kid died in a
car accident or your kid fell off a
[__] swing and he died you know
because we were younger like a 16 year
old kid dies you know 18 year old prom
kids die when they go to a prom and [__]
like that god forbid i'm talking about
this but it's the truth how many times
we put [__] stay away the heaven on
you know to mourn that person or
whatever in our own like it made you
think of that person or something so
there's been 50 [__] years of dead
bodies and people [__] thinking about
people that's the only reason i could
see why led zeppelin got the award it
would just untwist
so many [__] things at this point do
you follow me like how many albums would
they have to go back into
like anything they released after that
point would have to have them on it
it would be
50 years of [__] work reprinting
posters you know a whole lot of love was
stolen you know [__] like that i mean
what
how much work would you have to undo
emotionally
just you know and i wish they would have
gave something to the people like i wish
jimmy pagely said listen you should have
shut your [__] mouth and come to me
on the side i would have thrown you 10
g's or something a million dollars i
mean i wish zeppelin somewhere they find
a way maybe some undisclosed deal they
made to maybe throw them [__] a
million dollars i mean how much money
does zeppelin make off that [__] song
concerts you know the whole thing
included come on
so they're an interpretation band if you
go guys go on youtube
i'm not talking out of my ass now i had
to do this at night when there was
nobody around because i was so ashamed
on youtube there's
maybe six videos of people who have sat
down
and put leads up put the original
oh have you seen it [__] interesting
as [__] and it breaks your [__] heart
one night i started writing the songs
down and i couldn't because i knew i
couldn't listen to him the same
but then after you spoke a journey like
what do i give a [__] you know i just
want to listen to music i gotta get into
the [__] bowels of this [__]
but it does bother a guy like me you
know bothers a musician that people
could do this that
mike could go to his open mic on a
monday night
with one of his original songs that him
and his buddy wrote
and some [__] guitar attack
is in there and puts his phone on
to the band he works with
and just goes no then he goes home puts
his guitar on it whatever
and then he goes i'm not talking about a
guitar attack maybe a guitarist maybe a
rhythm guitarist
that you know is in a band and he's
struggling you know people like bands
they always say everybody has to bring
material in you know you want to get
from everybody a collaboration that's
what a band's about
so
i don't [__] know but they're the
best interpreters of all time and
there's times guys i'm not gonna lie to
you i've heard a joke that i say
maybe i should add that to it that to it
that to it
and i just mind my business
i don't want to go up to a comic ever
and go
hey you should add this tag that's none
of my business you know
while i'm with them
i could say the tag out loud
and if they hear it and they like it
they could take it that's their decision
but i would never go up to a comment
that's just me guys you know
i don't like a lot of these comics that
come up to you and want to [__] you
know i'm up here killing
you're up here sitting watching and
you're going to talk to me and i
understand there's a lot of guys that
are great writers and when they see you
they could [__] but there's some guys
i heard i had
somebody told me that one night they
were at a club and they were taping this
thing and a comic would go on there and
go don't use that joke
and he would go home at night and play
the recording and on the recording he
would hear the audience and then the
comic would say don't use that joke
don't you and then he you know he went
up to the comic when they said stop
saying that [__] to me
but those guys i think they could just
come up to you i would never go up to a
comic
and give them a tag you know how many
people have given me tags
one
one person gave me a tag i said it and i
got accused of being a [__] joke
thief
and i never said the joke again so
that's why i don't i would never go up
to you with something i don't expect you
to trust me
especially if i don't know you like if
josh wolf comes up to me or lee or mike
or somebody i know that i'm friends with
a long time and they're a comic and i
respect them a lot [__] yeah [__] yeah
i'll think about it at least i'll listen
to it
but just a random comic i i can't do it
because i don't know where the [__] they
got it from and then i'm the [__] bad
guy so
i don't even know how he got to
interpretations we got the music this
week i came here to talk to you
[__] about atlantic city
and uh how happy i was that i made it
down i was [__] pickles guys i'm not
gonna lie to you
i really was i was [__] pickles and
i you know guys i'm just uh i'm ashamed
sometimes i took off some time but i'm
not
this is why people make what's called a
comeback
this is what it's called now
so it's whatever i want to do i know
where i'm taking this come back to and
you always hear people say this i'm only
going to do a couple nights a week and
[__]
but i i'm getting old guys you know i
get tired i don't know how i'm going to
feel every day
i really miss
writing
i really miss sitting down and
like i journal you know i journal a lot
i write about what's going on
but i haven't really written comedy my
mind i can't lie to you in my mind you
know since you're out of it so long now
you got to get back in it
you know when you're a comic
i've learned how to become a comic by a
guy named roger holloway
roger holloway passed two years ago when
i moved here
roger holloway
in
like indirectly
without him knowing it or i knowing it
we develop the comedian's mind
a comedian's mind is when you're doing
when you're walking around
when you're doing normal things
it's not that you say something
it's that you think it it pops into your
head and you actually go
holy [__] that's funny that's the
comedian's mind
so for years
from hanging with him
through my you know high school it's
weird because i've been thinking about a
lot 40 years ago this month we graduated
high school all of us we were that tight
but uh
i was learning you know it was just an
amazing experience
i missed those guys a lot i miss what we
were but time goes on
he passed you know my other buddy glenn
is is busy i'm gonna hit him up this
week the other guy he's off the [__]
rails
but the best thing about roger was that
whenever you were with him he always had
a low voice
you know what i'm saying so
no matter what was going on he could
always hit you with a joke in your ear
and you would [__] die and it was the
funniest [__] thing in the world or
he would just turn his face and say
something take a look at this [__]
guy you know something like that to that
effect and you would lose it and i
remember in 85 being in boulder and
being without roger
for like i hadn't seen roger since uh
january of of new years of 85 and then i
saw him briefly before i left
and i'll never forget i remember walking
down the street to boulder and
just giggling having a [__]
party going on in my head look at this
guy's [__] sneakers how many dicks
did she suck last night look at this one
over here how fat is he you know just
and even if it's not right i know you
know i'm not shaming anybody i'm just in
my mind
you're working that machine gun that's
how it starts i really haven't had that
in a while yeah i say things to myself
sometimes i make myself laugh in the car
with a bad song or something but it's
not as strong as it was you know when i
was in it now i got to build that up
like i think the jokes and [__] when i'm
rapping when i'm talking to mike or
something mike might laugh and i go
that's a good joke but i'm not gonna
write that right now you know i don't
have time for that so
i just got to get that back going and
part of how do you get back that how do
you get
that going again is not by
sitting on your [__] ass
it's by [__] getting on stage so
i'll announce whatever dates i could get
once i start making dates like real
dates but for now i'm just gonna do
poppins at different clubs and uh
hopefully i'll bump into you
[__] this week
rich voss is in town next two weeks so
i'm thinking of going with him into the
city i mean ari's taping the special i
think it's next friday and
saturday so i'm thinking of going up
there and giving hari support he's
taping jew at one of the theaters i'm
sure if you go to
ari's webpage or his twitter he's got
the address or whatever i don't know
what it is i haven't spoke with him in a
few days but ari's doing that next week
jim norton's at uncle vinnie's
so i was thinking of going down there
maybe friday or saturday and catching my
friend jimmy he's a funny [__]
i don't know who's at the other clubs or
whatnot but yeah
huh helium it's really where next
weekend let's go down there and see
duncan do a podcast with him don't even
look i don't know oh they got shot by
south street yesterday who gives a [__]
like i said on stage the other night dog
philly will never be woke
they [__] won me over last week i'm
still [__] laughing about those
[__] anyway i love you
[__]
it's a great monday i won't let you go
[__] quickly uh
if you came to the shows i love you if
you didn't come to the shows you didn't
miss nothing we'll be back there
slinging dick
till the [__] end of time uh take
care have a great [__] day have a
great week and that's it [__]
it's your world
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack all right you bad
[__] i'm sorry i gave you any
beating today about [__] [__] you
don't need to know about but i had a
good time in atlantic city and for you
guys that want to know i'm happy i'm
back
the joint is brought to you by liquid iv
guys it's getting hotter out there
you're working out you're riding your
bike you're doing things you're hiking
listen
keep hydrated with liquid iv it's easy
to use one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water will hydrate you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone it contains five essential
vitamins b3 5 6 12 and vitamin c non-gmo
and free from gluten listen to me
don't dehydrate don't get those
headaches don't pass out on me liquid iv
is on a mission to change the world so
do me a favor grab liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco nice and easy oh
i'm gonna get you 25 off when you go to
liquid iv and use promo code joey at
checkout that's liquid iv and you use
code joey at checkout that's 25 off
anything when you use promo code joey at
checkout it's that easy uh
liquidity.com the joint is also brought
to you by draftkings listen this is the
week to make some cash you want money
for the fourth of july to jump up and
down on the beach ufc 275 is the atm
machine you understand me and draftking
sportsbook is laying it down this
weekend the official sports betting
partner the ufc better fit to get in
five hours on ufc 275 and get 150 in
free bets instantaneously you understand
me knockout submission a kick to the nut
sack i don't give a [__] now if you're
looking for a bigger payday check out
draftking sportsbook newest ufc feature
same game paulie's you can make a lot
more money
double your [__] winnings
with the same game parlay for saturday
night okay i would give it to you but
i'm not doing that no more i'm just
[__] trying to help you out with
draftkings download the draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
throw down finals and then the ufc 275
fight and get 150 and free bets
instantly that's co joey this saturday
at draftkings sports book the official
sports betting partner of the ufc listen
to me i want to thank liquid iv and i
want to thank draftkings for always
taking it to the [__] hoop
let's make some cash [__] up this i'll
be back wednesday
tip top magoo stay black uncle joey
loves you
[Music]
you